welcome everybody it is time for drew's
news your daily news corn on the cob
covered in that good news butter and
with me at the desk my trusty co-pilot
rossi ross matthews
stick around to the end of the show
because today guess what day it is rossi
my favorite day pop quiz yes
that's right i do love pop quiz one
lucky audience number is going to be in
the hot seat we'll ask you three
questions about today's show and if you
get it right you get a thousand dollars
all right so pay attention
i love pop quiz and we don't even know
what the questions are gonna be so you
have to pay attention everything i
always play along me too and i'm always
proud of myself when i know the answer
even though
all right well first up this story
really speaks to me and i'm excited to
tell you about it so the oscars are a
month away and this year the 94 year old
show
is trying something new
variety reports that fans can now vote
for their favorite movie of 2021
that's right you can vote on twitter or
the oscars website
until march 3rd
and you can pick any movie that you
think was the year's best results will
be announced live on the stage on the
oscars
i i don't even know where to unpack this
bag but
why
this hasn't happened sooner i love this
you see millions of people writing in
you know for the american idols of the
world fan participation
is a wonderful thing i am so excited
about this me too listen i love the
oscars it is my new year's my christmas
everything i love the oscars but there
are some years when like what's voted on
is the best doesn't really reflect what
audiences are gonna go see so i'm on
board i mean girl can i get a time
machine go back to 1989 and vote for
steele magnolias over and over and over
again because
don't talk about me like i'm not here
juice is better
yes i am i agree i also think in this
new modern era
don't be archaic and so snooty falooti
let's get the fans in there absolutely
and it's a way to honor like for example
this year spider-man you know there was
a lot of did you guys see i mean
everybody in the planet saw spider-man
there's a lot of buzz it could be
nominated for best picture because it
brought so many audiences out to the
theater again it missed it but here's a
chance and i think that's probably the
leader don't you think for for this fan
voted award i feel like it might get my
vote for sure oh you that's a good
question is drew barrymore going to like
go to twitter and vote i absolutely am i
love the oscars but i always felt like
some connection
to
fans and moviegoers was missing and this
might be the piece i've been waiting for
yeah i think they finally figured it out
94 years hi great job thanks oscars
picking it up so the results
will be announced live on the stage at
the oscars on march 27th and i gotta
tell you
i will always watch every oscars but
this year i will be really excited for
this i know and i guess i now am an
academy member because i'm voting yeah
exactly
yeah when they say thank you we like
save the academy you're welcome
all right next up for you drew you know
showbiz is a family affair and that's
true for the apatows too you know
director jed apatow he put his daughters
mod and iris in his movies for years and
now mods all grown up and she's starring
in euphoria which is like the most
buzzed about show all the rage well
here's some more news people reports
that the apatows are you know they like
to kid around with each other and when
mod recently posted about the latest
episode of euphoria here's what judd
replied her dad said i'll watch it right
after i finish yellowstone
which i know is your favorite show
i love it so much well i have news to
tell you so i'm you know it takes me a
minute to decide whether i'm going to
binge a show because it's very serious
right and i've been telling you please
binge yellowstone well i want you to
know that i today pushed download on
season one and so i will be starting it
on the train today yellowstone you may
have just converted me
in that way
matthews buckle up and then we can talk
about like who's more exciting and
appealing because they all vie for
first place it's so fun
[Music]